- Max?
Bring mir bitte einen Champagner, ja?
- Inge! Gibt's was zu feiern?
- Nein …
ich hab' mich nur gerade an eine
besondere … Begegnung erinnert.
- Ach, ich würde auch gerne
einen Champagner trinken.
- Du trinkst Orangensaft!
- Ja, ist ja gut! Ich meine ja nur …
Es wäre schön, wenn ich
jetzt ein Glas trinken könnte.
- Oh mein Gott.
- Oh, ich heul' gleich.
- Oh Gott. Ich glaube, ich auch.
- Inge!
Vor vielen …
vielen Jahren bin ich
von zu Hause weggegangen.
Ich habe nicht nur
meine Arbeit verloren,
ich habe mich verloren.
Otto gab es nicht mehr.
Nur noch Jacques.
Nur noch Lügen,
nur noch Unwahrheiten.
Und dann kamst du, Inge.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich
Jacques mal nicht mehr brauche.
Aber es ist soweit.
Ich will heimkehren.
Ich will nie wieder lügen und nie wieder
jemandem weh tun, vor allem dir nicht.
Ich wünsche mir nichts mehr,
als mein Leben mit dir zu verbringen,Inge.
Ich liebe dich!
Willst du meine Frau werden?
- Ist der Champagner …?
- … bezahlt?
Ja.
- Ich glaube dir, Otto.
Und ich wünsche mir auch,
deine Frau zu werden.
- Champagner, Champagner, Champagner!
- Oh …
Auf die Liebe!